uh section of our
Workshop um it'll be all deep learning
all three talks and we start with an
appropriate title and Zach IES thank you
well uh and thanks everybody for the
opportunity to participate in what's
been a really interesting uh uh mind
expanding Workshop uh so you know I kind
of picked this title in part as a little
bit of a pun you know how do you put
deep learning uh into the way we think
about C processing I should um put a
disclaimer I'm not claiming in any way
this is going to be a deep talk
um but actually uh uh I would love to um
get some early feedback and potential
collaborations um in a problem space
that we've been uh just kind of starting
to think about um for the uh past few
months uh which I think is starting to
build some interesting uh interesting
problems so um I'm sure you've all
noticed where living in this interesting
time where uh more and more of the data
that people are starting to play with
can feasibly be pulled off the open uh
internet whether you've got Transformers
or GPT or whatever um we're increasingly
seeing things uh where um sort of makes
sense to think about there being a
database that we can analyze but the
database doesn't actually uh end up
being the central repository for the
data uh rather it's more like a
materialized view of stuff extracted off
uh the open web so you know in a way uh
maybe the simplest not as new
abstraction of this is think of Google
Scholar right so Google Scholar is a
full-blown database it's got the ability
to do things with it you know you could
imagine if they made it fully available
and maybe semantic scholar is a better
uh version of this you could do data
science type things you could build
dashboards they obviously have a query
and a search interface you know you
could really think of this as an SQL
database um but of course everything
that's in it uh originates somewhere
else uh and I think the interesting
question is um you know if we were to
really Embrace that model right where we
have a thing that looks like a database
it's queriable it's you can do stuff
with it but the data actually lives
elsewhere uh and is extracted and linked
today uh based on embeddings based on
other learned measures uh you know what
uh would such a system look like and how
do we actually make it uh perform well
um and you know I think a lot of my
interest has been you know can the ideas
of uh quer optimization view update view
maintenance um Etc actually make sense
in this uh kind of new world of course
um in keeping with the themes of this
Workshop uh also there's a you know lots
of interesting opportunities for
thinking about uh Providence okay so uh
just to give a few examples of some very
simple um uh use case queries that we
might come up with in this broad space
you know you could think of very simple
kind of selection queries you know I
have PDF uh papers and we have a a
Transformer that extracts out titles and
authors and venues and citations right
um and generally we tend to think of
that as some blackbox userdefined
function um but part of what will come
out is not just the Tuple but probably
some kind of label or class prediction
or whatever and you can actually think
about there being kind of a threshold
somewhere in your query which is like
only do this if we think it's accurate
up to you know some confidence level
okay um we can have more General
versions right um uh there actually a
ton of places where people seem to um
monitor social media for mentions of
their products or their favorite
celebrity or or what have you uh and
build dashboards and so on I guess
probably more if you're a publicity
person or something like that
uh where you might be monitoring well I
guess I can't say Twitter anymore X and
Facebook with different extractors that
do kind of the same thing again you can
Union things together and produce a
result and we might actually want to
think about Providence now because did
this come from Twitter or did it come
from X uh oops uh and maybe the more
interesting one um I'll touch on this uh
late at the end um uh might be something
that's not even in our normal database
comfort zone think about situations
where we have um security monitoring and
video frames well now we have the
ability to deal with these through
embeddings uh so imagine you take video
frames and you want to actually uh
preserve privacy of the folks who are
supposed to be in the lobby so uh we
detect all the faces in the frame we
convert them to embeddings now we do a
similarity join with the faces of people
who we know and actually we go back and
basically take those images and blur out
everybody who's supposed to be there and
we only get to see the the folks who
shouldn't be there right there's lots of
these kinds of applications uh that you
can come up with and you can see each of
them is kind of again I'm I'm picking
simple examples they're basically let's
say unions of conjunctive queries with
um some ml components somewhere along
the way okay um so that's the space
we're interested in um of course the
first question is if you're going to put
all these things in um how do we sort of
generalize let's say a
streaming database query model or even a
standard relational model um to deal
with this uh there are lots of different
approaches in fact um I think I don't
see
uh at first glance I don't see Meer here
but he'll probably talk about it oh
there sorry there we are he'll probably
talk about different formalisms uh for
this but basically you know there's a
question of how do you combine tuples
and tensors and vectors I'm going to
claim that uh the way that we want to do
this is just to think about a standard
relational model where we add a tensor
data type uh and then you have to think
a little bit about adding some extra
algebraic operations but basically at
some level pandas already has these so
we can you know more or less uh steal
these things for moving between fields
and vectors and exploding things and
nesting them and stacking tensors and
and so on okay so uh broadly for the
rest of my talk I'm going to sort of
assume we have this extended algebra uh
and sort of see uh what what we can do
um and our interest is really in this
question of okay how do we do effic
query processing again I'm going to
think of both updates and queries in
this model um that sort of combines what
we know from structured queries like
constraints and algebraic equivalences
uh with these sort of uh more uh
numerically generated machine learning
stages with tensors and Dot products and
activation functions and so on um and
ideally there's some Synergy between the
two that we can exploit to get better
performance okay now there's lots of
different areas you can look at um uh
you know uh mayor and I have talked at
various points and uh certainly I've
read a lot of his papers and there's
this whole interesting area coming from
sort of outside the DB Community called
neuros symbolic reasoning uh and uh deep
proog is another example of um a system
in the space uh where I would say like
at
least what I have interpreted from the
community is the focus very much is that
by putting these things together you can
learn better uh and do better
predictions okay the part I interested
in is um suppose we're just mostly
focused on the prediction side can we
actually do updates and uh maintenance
and so on uh a lot better okay so we
want to
basically go into the neural network uh
and uh break it into its individual
components and hopefully get some
synergies by thinking about that so
again I'm going to expand my set of
operators uh again not inventing
anything new at some level pie torch and
tensor flow and all of the other kind of
deep learning toolkits already have this
uh data flow graph type model with
various ways of connecting neural
network activation units and uh scaling
data and and so on so we're going to
expand our uh vocabulary with those um
and then start to look at queries okay
so this is probably about the simplest
version of a query I can come up with
that has a neural network component
suppose we have a conjunctive query it
produces a set of tpls uh so I'm going
to show Tuple as having let's say three
Fields like this uh that'll feed into
the neural network model it will produce
a label which we're just going to add as
another field because we want to be able
to expose this to our query language
okay um and of course that's one version
but a more interesting version might be
well my Tuple comes in with Providence
and I want to uh propagate that through
my uh machine learning model and
actually uh create the label and have
some kind of Providence uh on the output
okay um that's not really the end of the
pipeline in general we're going to have
some additional relational stuff maybe
at minimum um some selection threshold
for confidence on one or more uh classes
okay so this is probably the simplest
query that we can come up with uh and
I'm going to use this as a little bit of
an example to sort of show uh some of
what we can do uh and also I guess
exercise PowerPoints uh fancy
transitions um so this is the same query
but I've kind of rotated at 90 degrees
so we can drill down um so again I have
a relation down here let's suppose that
it's maybe R joint s it's got a sequence
of tuples uh we're going to feed those
one at a time into our machine learning
model we're going to get out uh labels
that will concatenate onto the tups um
within the neural network uh again we
have a set of things that looks very
much like our uh familiar relational
operators but they all work on vectors
and uh tensors um so roughly speaking
what will happen here is we'll take each
Tuple uh and actually feed it into
different layers in the neural network
uh this is I will say not a deep neural
network but pretend that it is uh we
have two layers here so each Tuple uh if
its features were numerically valued
what will happen is uh we will multiply
the feature values by the weights uh for
one of these activation units this is
just a DOT product uh and then normally
the output gets mapped into some uh um
subset of possible values so what relu
does is basically it truncates negative
values at uh zero um we will often feed
the same data into multiple of these in
parallel because each of these will
essentially extract will learn different
combinations of features uh and predict
some higher level uh basically deriv
feature uh and this continues sort of
through uh the neural network at each
level we're doing a DOT product followed
by some particular uh function okay uh
so I think that is what's called feed
forward in a neural network um in the
simplest uh nutshell now one question is
uh how do we want to think about tups
that go through this um especially if we
have Providence annotations on The
Originals uh what should the Providence
on the outputs be uh there are lots of
ways you can think about this the way
that we have modeled the neural network
is to really think about it as kind of a
external userdefined function and um
essentially model it uh more or less as
doing a dependent join with some
external relation so the neural network
is some other relation I have bindings
to my features I send it over to the
neural network I get back a set of
tuples that get joined uh with the input
and if I do that then I can get
Providence to be some product of uh the
prevence expression of the original plus
well times uh some uh function symbol
over uh whatever went into the neural
network okay so that's kind of how we
think about um uh Providence in this
model now um so far we've just produced
the output of a view uh there's a
interesting question of course of how do
we let end users correct the fact that
there's a lot of likely gibberish in the
views um and the simplest way to do this
which I'm only going to sketch uh is to
do some kind of um incremental machine
learning uh and the way this typically
works is you know you make a prediction
on the output here uh which is why hat
this is my label it is wrong let's say
the user says you know uh delete this or
change its score or whatever so normally
you'll compute a loss which is a penalty
for being wrong uh and then propagate
that loss back through the neural
network uh and actually um this is my
one slide connecting to semi-rings uh
there's very nice work that uh I first
uh became familiar with through Myer's
work on scallop uh but dates back to
Jason Eisner who was building a system
called Dina for natural language
processing uh and deterministic sorry
and um uh weighted uh finite State
transducers uh with a thing called a
gradient semi- ring and the idea here is
uh Providence becomes pair of a score
and a gradient vector and they Define uh
a set of um uh operations for the plus
and the times like this where you can
add the probabilities and the gradients
for the sum uh you can multiply the
probabilities and then you do the
product rule when you multiply the
gradients and this effectively captures
exactly what P torch does today in this
thing called autograd where whenever it
makes a prediction it logs the gradients
so that it can can uh do stochastic
radiant descent okay uh so uh again this
is not going to be the focus of uh my
talk uh but somewhere that will happen
um what
uh uh my students and I have been
interested in is thinking about now
given an update we have this view how do
you actually compute or recompute uh the
results of the view okay and uh what
we've convinced ourselves uh which I
hope might be uh something of of broader
interest is um there are opportunities
for taking ideas from uh
relational uh crr evaluation um and
applying them in this context um so the
first thing I want to show you is a kind
of a special case of sideways
information passing uh where uh we can
actually make uh the processing of the
data through the neural network much
faster or more efficient uh and then the
second thing is really thinking about
what it means to have equivalences when
you have a neural network uh in the
middle okay so uh let's come back to our
simplified um illustration of a uh Tuple
going into a two- layer neural network
I've slightly simplified the version
from a couple of slides ago but this is
basically the same thing I take a tuple
let's say it only has two features now
I'm G to um
run it through two activation units
where the T will get multiplied by the
weights we uh do Ru we take the outputs
as two features we wait those and then
we do a a sigmoid function at the end
okay um so this is slightly simplifying
things I'm removing a few details uh
just to focus on the gist uh of the
computation okay so
um here is I think the interesting uh
opportunity here if you look at at this
kind of a query almost always we have a
label with a numerical value and we're
going to have some threshold here before
we count it as being interesting or
belonging to our class or whatever so
the question is can we uh essentially do
a sideways information passing type idea
to take this constraint and what we know
about values throughout this thing and
compute thresholds to
prun the processing through the neural
network right uh uh in many ways you
know if you're familiar uh with Fagan's
algorithm and the basic notion uh of um
trying to threshold or bound all of the
data that you haven't seen uh our
Insight is that you can do uh similar
things um with a neural network in this
relational setting uh if you uh are
allowed to do a little bit of setup in
advance okay so basically um what we
need is a way way of putting a bound on
all of the data that we haven't seen uh
or another way of putting it is we would
like to propagate data through uh our
neural network uh in monotonically
decreasing order of score okay uh so
that's the basic idea again it's very
much um like what uh the threshold
algorithm does but we're not looking for
top K we're looking for anything above
Max yes set up like the r are fixed in
the okay so generally speaking the
weights are fixed until we do a cycle
of SGD and then we and the key is when
we relearn the weights the question is
going to be how do we recompute all of
our output now most likely if you update
the weights you only change them in a
small amount so most likely the set of
instances in the view is almost the same
right that's what we're intuitively
going to rely on yes the provence at the
end takes into account that but the sigo
functions or yes so okay so assume that
the sigo function is well defined on the
is it only
for negative weight uh okay so okay let
me see if I can there's a bunch of
details that I'm gonna uh kind of
postpone but basically uh if you go back
to that gradient semi- ring that I
hinted at that is going to uh
essentially one way I thinking about it
is it logs the derivative of the sigmoid
at the point that I made the
prediction that's right yes yes this is
not a in fact this is one of the
interesting questions that we might want
to talk about after okay okay so we're
okay yes
Joe yeah ranking topk type of stuff why
do we have competing candidates of
output here I'm not even seeing that
sorry uh competing candidates okay by
other potential outputs no okay so let
me let me restate the problem I have a
large set of
tupal say 1% of them are going to be
interesting
events okay so I want a printing
strategy where I don't have to look at
all of them in order to find the 1% does
that make sense so but is the threshold
rank based or is the threshold sort of
metric based okay this threshold is
metric based and we we haven't yet gone
into the example so it might become more
clear when we the example but basically
we have a hard
threshold uh we will however want to set
things
up
uh in particular way that we can read
the data uh in a monotonically
decreasing order in general okay so the
idea here is I take my table and I'm
much like again with Fagan's algorithm I
can build some unclustered indices on
the table I'm going to pick a subset of
the features that I think are
important and basically now I can read
all of the results of T in decreasing
order by F1 or by have2 okay there a
combination of these metrics coming in
that lead to yeah so so why don't I go
through the example and we can see if it
makes sense okay so I've set this up in
a way that's you know slightly um
simplified but let's pretend that um
those details aren't there so the basic
idea is I have a set of Weights these
are already set from training or
initialization or
whatever um I have a data set that I'm
going to be continuously going over so I
can pre-index it okay and I'm going to
pre-index it by F1 and F2 and so uh I'm
going to just draw this as so here's the
key
99 and here's the whole Tuple T1 right
and so T1 has values of 99 for F1 and F2
uh that will be the highest value for F1
and the highest value for F2 okay again
if you think of if you're familiar with
Pagan's algorithm you're reading
intram monotonic order same idea here
okay so when I do this right uh what
we'll happen is I'll take this T1 Tuple
which I've seen in both places I will
propagate it through my neural net at
the first level I will multiply the 99
to by 0.5 and add 99 time3 and the Rue
which for a positive number we'll just
pass it through okay at this point I
know there's no value of T1 with a value
of F2 greater than 99 and same for F2
but I also have a bound on the output of
the ru because the weights are fixed and
positive and my data is
monotonically decreasing okay uh and I
can do the same thing on this side with
the same Tuple through the second
activation unit and then uh propagate it
up and this is above my 0.9 by a tiny
margin so all is good okay uh so now uh
the question is how many more tuples do
I need to read before I can be convinced
that there's nothing else that's going
to score above .9 okay so I will consume
from my index the next one let's say is
88 this gives me an updated bound on
this value because it can't be more than
88 plus the well scaled 88 and 99 uh and
also it Updates this value and I can
keep reading until I get uh uh
additional Ts that show up in both
indices and then I propagate them now I
know there's nothing bigger than 15 here
and nothing bigger than 28 here uh and
if I propagate this through these are
already below the threshold and
basically by reading fre tuples I have
skipped huge portions of my data set and
I don't even need to run the classifier
on anything for most of these okay so
that's the basic idea
yes strong
restriction okay that's for the example
there is a generalization yes in fact uh
why don't I just um slightly elaborate
on that this is a sketch of uh the basic
algorithm in fact uh so first of all
your weight could be negative in which
case you have to go in the other
order uh and the more interesting thing
is it could start you could change the
weight where it started positive and
then it flipped negative or vice versa
okay so there's some details but by and
large you can use this thresholding and
sideways information passing idea in an
neural network and actually uh you know
get the benefits of of standard database
queries plus neural networks with you
know database style techniques uh pretty
well okay actually my my um former
student Peter Chen ran this and then
said okay let's compare it to P torch
with a GPU guess what um all too often P
torch with the GPU still won because it
was doing like 5,000 times more work but
Hardware is a very powerful thing right
uh so sometimes the GPU still wins of
course using a lot more energy
but the interesting place where uh
essentially we found we always won is
this view maintenance version of thing
so I computed the output once now I do
some minor weight
updates now I want to recompute so
basically you take all the things you
previously outputed you re-update the
scores you might have to throw a few
away because they no longer satisfy the
threshold then you just read enough
additional tups under the new scoring
model uh to potentially uh satisfy the
new threshold and and you're done okay
so again the main idea here is um this
is to my knowledge the first time we've
actually managed to put these two ideas
you know kind of a database style uh
constraints and um uh kind of neural
network feed forward into the same
framework and actually get uh some
pretty meaningful benefits um uh let's
see how am I doing on time probably uh
need to finish soon so I'll just say uh
our results even against ptor with the
GPU we got up to 8X speedups uh when the
number of members of the class was you
know up to 10% of the uh overall data
which we think is actually quite
realistic for many kinds of extraction
and event detection stuff you're not
expecting 50% of your data to be an
interesting event right uh okay so side
was information passing actually can be
integrated into deep learning uh to Big
benefits okay uh I want to just tease uh
one other idea that took us a long time
to come up with which was thinking about
um PR expression equivalence okay uh so
here's our setting um the kind of video
processing version that I talked about
we have a video stream coming at 15
frames a second you want to process the
data extracting faces competing
embeddings and seeing who's in the frame
okay actually the speed of this pipeline
is going to vary tremendously between
there's no faces in the frame to
suddenly there's a
crowd right now if you have some kind of
latency or throughput guarantee that you
need to have like you keep up with a
video frame uh we have a bit of a
problem okay so what we would like to do
is take advantage of the fact that um
you can build different classifiers that
essentially do the same task right um I
think the
problem uh that at least we wrestled
with for a long time is what does it
mean for two classifiers to be
equivalent
what does it mean for two query sub
expressions with a classifier to be
equivalent and I think our conclusion
ultimately is that actually doesn't ever
happen um you take the same neural
network and you train it with different
random initialization parameters and you
get different performance so it's not so
much you can actually say they're
equivalent uh but perhaps they're sort
of functionally equivalent and perhaps
you can create a total or a partial
ordering on your preference of them and
of course you have different uh
performance characteristics for each uh
so with that basic observ ation uh it's
possible to actually come up in with
ways of switching between alternative
classifiers and so on even in an
Adaptive way uh so actually very much
based on um Joe and Ron avner's uh work
from I think it was 2000 right uh on
Eddy uh we tried to take a similar
approach so basically you want to use
your most accurate classifier as much as
possible but when it starts to get
oversaturated you want to turn on and
potentially flip to uh faster but less
high quality
classifier but you also want to putli
back the moment that you can so
basically taking many of the ideas of
eddes uh the idea here is we have kind
of our pipeline that does the accurate
neural network there's a Que in front of
it we have kind of a router in front uh
as frames come in if they start to pile
up after some threshold you enable an
alternate branch and now you have a
randomized strategy that uh prefers cues
that have uh less um uh less load in
them uh and you'll kind of randomize
across these things uh preferring the
ones that are faster but still using the
slower more accurate one where you can
and eventually when things kind of clear
out you'll actually disable the one you
don't prefer and move forward okay so
that's our basic idea the main thing
here uh that uh I found to be uh
personally gratifying is
um the notion of equivalence
uh is sort of fundamental the way we
think about the world and it just really
doesn't actually work um in uh
classifier world but there are
alternative ways we can think about this
so uh let me wrap up Val said I had now
probably a minute and a half left uh I
think this problem of trying to build
maintainable updatable views over the
results of machine learning plus queries
uh provides a really interesting test
bit I do think there are lots of
applications that look like this today
and people are just batch rerunning the
whole thing and not allowing them to be
updated that isn't the way the world
should be um there are connections to
Providence here view updates side was
information passing equivalents and so
on uh would love to talk more this is
really just first early steps in the
space uh but uh I think there are lots
of connections and lots of ideas that
have come through the last couple of
days I will just put up uh in wrapping
up a few of the um uh open problems that
I think are quite interesting in this
space one of which is this great semi-
ring model uh I think it's quite
interesting that it captures enough
information that you can propagate
updates backward through and kind of
blame each input unit accordingly and
actually get something that's well
formed uh I wonder if there are
generalizations of that idea that Mak
sense in other uh query contexts so with
that uh I will stop and happy to take
any questions thank
[Applause]
you okay we have done for one question
question so the right so this Pagan
algorithm idea right this would only
work right if if there is some kind of
linear property that the network behaves
linear in this one dimension right that
I can just increase it couldn't be
something like where a higher value I go
lower and then lower I get again a
higher score right um and that's not
guaranteed right um sorry um which part
okay so there there's several different
aspects here right so if I'm using a
neural network generally I will have
product as my first function here now
what I'm relying on is the activation
function also
is for at least certain parts of the
range uh also monotonic in the sort of
Haagen sense uh so realu actually for
negative numbers you kind of have to
ignore that but that's actually a place
where neural networks don't work anyway
well I mean basically theu makes it
powerful right without the I just set a
linear model right yes although again
sigmoid I always have sigmoid option
right so anyway I guess what I would
say as succinctly as I can is I think if
you look at at least all of the neural
network uh setups that I have seen in
the general case they satisfy the
properties that we're relying on so that
they monotone in each dimension in the S
again the like basic building block in
the neural network is this linear
combination of sure features right so
that part is yeah yeah but I mean there
might also be negative ways there but if
yeah actually the algorithm generalizes
that so you basically just you have to
flip your read from smallest to most
negative to most positive
and right so no for the linear part I
think I agree but I have to think I
don't understand right it works for for
right basically activation function that
is whose purpose it is to make it
nonlinear right because otherwise I
could start with a linear model okay
note that it's usually the composition
of the linear functions that I'm relying
on especially right relu is linear for
half of its domain
right it's just you know chunk zero
otherwise linear basically saying I can
replace my new network with a linear
function at each level I have to
recursively do this threshold thing okay
that make sense okay cool okay um thank
you very much so we we going to go again